[up-tempo music]
[music continues]
So, you got time
to talk about this?
We need to get together
on this build.
Didn't think this day
was ever gonna come.
Yeah, I got time.
Let's go do it.
You got unlimited resources,
as far as I'm concerned,
but I don't know
what's in your mind,
so I gotta have
some kind of rough idea,
you know,
what the plan is.
Why don't we do something
in the ceiling, like,
badass deals up here?
So they can get up there
and walk on it.
So, you want some sort
of handrail around it?
Gotta get up there
and hang out.
Let's say that's
the outside, right?
I mean, what are we
gonna do on the inside?
You got all this badass going
on, come on, what do we got?
Well, I mean, that's
a badass outside, right?
So, the inside of it,
you said you need cabinets
on the top on both sides.
-Yeah, that's--
-So, I don't know yet.
-I get the cabinets.
-I don't know yet.
I'll figure out
something.
Well, how-- Can I throw some
ideas out there and you
soak on them a little bit?
Do it.
What if you put a solid,
hardwood wall and floor
in that [bleep]?
-All right.
-Whatever. I mean,
why not just make it sexy?
Y'all went that far.
-Let's do it. It'll work.
-What do you think?
It'll work, but what
do you think, though?
-Yeah.
-It'll work? All right.
I got one more idea
we throw out there with you.
You don't have to go
with any of this at all.
But what if this whole side
of this thing right here...
you got your fender boxes
come out like this,
what if this whole
son-of-a-[bleep] was clear?
What if the whole side of it
was some kind of plexiglass?
But I need you to kinda be able
to come up with these ideas.
It's killer.
I mean, you make it
a reality?
I'll-I'll help you with it,
going through reality,
but we just--
It's my challenge, baby.
I'll handle it.
There's 30 days.
When you say 30 days,
-It's not 40-hours a week
for 30 days.
-I got it. I know.
I got you.
There's 24 hours in a day.
You need three hours of sleep.
Anyways, back to this.
All right, so we're
going in the back door.
What are we gonna see
on the walls?
I don't know.
Figure that out.
-I love [bleep] speakers.
-Yeah, I need speakers--
-I mean, why not?
-Yeah. I'm 24-years-old, dude.
What do you think?
-You got it.
-It's a lot of work.
[laughs] It's gonna be tough,
but that's okay.
I'll help you figure it out.
Come on, give me some.